well the creepy porn lawyer certainly
has lived a glamorous life it turns out
during the few waking moments he hasn't
spent on cable television
he has raced cars with a Saudi prince
he's flown private to visit 5-star
hotels in the French Riviera he once
owned a seven million dollar home in
Southern California it's good being the
creepy porn lawyer but with a first name
like creepy it's no surprise that mr.
porn lawyer financed that lifestyle in
part by simply refusing to pay the money
he owed other people according to an
extensive and fascinating report in The
Daily Beast
Cpl and his businesses have millions of
dollars in unpaid state and federal
taxes earlier this year creepy porn
Warner's law firm was ordered to pay ten
million dollars to a former partner whom
he apparently stiffed on profits from
the firm the firm did not pay up so
today the creepy porn lawyer was hit
with a personal judgment of four point
eight million dollars not even the
creepy porn lawyers landlords are
getting a cut of that though in a court
in Santa Ana California convicted his
law firm evicted rather the law firm
from its offices for simply skipping
four months of rent nobody from the firm
even bothered to show up at the hearing
maybe that would have been different if
the hearing had been held inside a CNN
news studio